Режим тривоги через скорочення поставок газу -
питання до міністра Габека;
розчарування і надія - ЄС вирішує долю
країн-кандидатів на вступ до ЄС;
нескінченне очікування - тіснота в аеропортах.
В ефірі «heute journal» з Гансом Вольфом
та Марієттою Сломкою.
Добрий вечір.
Україна та Молдова отримали статус
кандидатів на вступ до Європейського Союзу.
Рішення, яке сьогодні ухвалили глави
держав та урядів Європейського Союзу,
вже називають історичним.
Детальніше про цю важливу подію далі у випуску.
Спершу поговоримо про економічні наслідки
російської війни в Україні,
які сколихнули всю Європу та зумовили суттєвий
перерозподіл сил у Європейському Союзі.
Міністр економіки Німеччини Роберт Габек
оголосив про перехід до режиму тривоги
через скорочення запасів газу.
Це другий етап аварійного плану на випадок
надзвичайної ситуації в газовому секторі.
Третій етап означатиме оголошення
надзвичайної ситуації в країні
та передбачатиме втручання держави, а саме -
розподіл квот на постачання газу споживачам.
На щастя, до третього етапу поки що не дійшло.
Габек б'є на сполох передусім задля того,
щоб великі підприємста та приватні
домогосподарства були напоготові,
адже попереду - зима.
Френк Бухвальд розповість більше.
Подібні заяви не даються легко.
Проте в Роберта Габека не було іншого виходу.
Відтепер газ - це дефіцитний товар для Німеччини.
Повідомляю вам про це зазадалегідь, незважаючи на
те, що наразі ситуація з газопостачанням контрольована.
Нагадаємо, що перший етап аварійного плану -
так званий режим раннього попередження
було запроваджено 30 березня.
Сьогодні ж міністр Габек офіційно оголосив
про перехід до режиму тривоги.
У разі запровадження надзвичайного стану
Федеральне агентство з мереж Німеччини
зможе ухвалювати рішення про те, хто
отримає газ, а хто ні.
Поки що до цього не дійшло, однак...
Якщо промисловому та приватному сектору
не вдасться заощадити достатню кількість газу
або знайти інші джерела його отримання,
зима буде «суворою».
Наразі сховища природного газу заповнені
лише наполовину.
Про те, що цього замало, говорить,
зокрема, і опозиція.
Вона вимагає від уряду чіткого плану,
коаліція відразу ж реагує.
Ми тижнями вимагаємо від уряду чіткого плану.
Країна має бути готовою до різних
сценаріїв розвитку подій.
Ми працюємо максимально оперативно,
щоб ситуація в країні лишалася стабільною.
Не знаю, чи ви помітили, пане Шпан,
але наш план полягає у подоланні кризи,
до якої саме ви довели нашу країну.
Ось такий план, пане Шпан!
Поставки газу Росією дедалі зменшуються.
Поставки газу з Росії до Європи газогоном Ямал-Європа
на компресорній станції Мальновфактично припинилися.
Мегальним трубопроводом до Вайдгаусу надходить
лише третина колишніх об'ємів.
А через «Північний потік-1» надходить
на 60% менше газу.
На цьому проблеми не закінчуються.
Нам лишається тільки очікувати, коли постачання
через «Північний потік-1» буде повністю припинене.
Це питання часу. А ми досі не вирішили,
як діятимемо далі.
Погані новини, особливо для споживачів.
Ми очікуємо, що вже цього року домогосподарствам
доведеться платити на 1000 – 2000 євро більше.
Протягом року ця сума може значно зрости.
Поки що постачальники можуть збувати газ
споживачам за дещо нижчими цінами,
ніж на світовому енергоринку.
Однак це не надовго.
Ніхто не хотів, щоб так сталося.
Але ми повинні шукати вихід із цієї ситуації разом.
Інакше кажучи, ми маємо розробити новий
інструментарій,
щоб постачальники не лишилися один-на-один
із новими високими цінами.
Проте це ще не всі погані новини на сьогодні -
якщо вугільні електростанції
вироблятимуть більше електроенергії,
сучасні газові електростанції буде зачинено.
Не найкращий день для міністра економіки та
захисту клімату, який, до того ж, є членом партії Зелених.
Про це ми зараз і поспілкуємося
з Робертом Габеком.
Доброго вечора, пане Габек.
- Вітаю Вас.
Отже, з огляду на ситуацію, Вам доводиться
діяти перш за все як міністру економіки,
відклавши думки про захист клімату?
Ваша правда, це складне рішення.
Не буду ходити околяса -
я справді хотів зменшити
частку вугільної енергетики,
а зараз нам доведеться поновити роботу
навіть давно зачинених електростанцій,
зважаючи на надзвичайну ситуацію з газопостачанням.
Також ми посилено працюємо над розвитком
екологічного сектору вітроенергетики.
На розгляд Бундестагу вже подано 7-8 законів.
Попит на вітрову енергетику лише зростатиме.
Промисловість прагне якнайшвидше відмовитися від
викопних, тобто непоновлюваних, джерел енергії.
Ми вже почали впроваджувати масштабні
програми з підвищення енергоефективності,
стартувало відповідне оновлення будівель.
Нарешті справа зрушила з мертвої точки.
Можемо спостерігати справді чудову динаміку.
Тому, навіть якщо мені щось і не подобається,
я втішаю себе думкою про те,
що варто зачекати, бодай 4 роки,
і, можливо, тоді, результат
виправдає усі нашу сподівання.
Так, але зараз ми не бачимо жодних результатів.
Не бачимо офіційних дозволів на будівництво
мільйонів вітрових електростанцій,
а отже все ще не почуваємося
в енергетичній безпеці.
У Вас справді була поважна причина для
впровадження другого етапу аварійного плану.
І Ви навіть готові повернути до
експлуатації давно зачинені ТЕСи,
оскільки відновлюваних джерел
енергії наразі недостатньо.
Перш за все, варто пояснити, навіщо нам
узагалі потрібен газ.
Частка газу на ринку електроенергії
становить 15%.
Це правда.
Ми зменшимо або взагалі позбавимося цих
15% за рахунок вугільних електростанцій.
А вугільні електростанції, у свою чергу, в майбутньому
зможемо замінити сонячними та вітровими.
Понад 30% газу витрачається на опалення наших
будівель, на нагрівання води,
а також на потреби промисловості.
Проте існують і інші енергоносії.
Так, відновлювані джерела енергії використовуються
зазвичай опосередковано,
наприклад, для видобутку газу.
А водень можна отримати шляхом електролізу.
Тобто, збільшення частки зелених джерел енергії
є ключовим пунктом подолання
енергетичної залежності від Кремля в майбутньому.
Ми вже можемо спостерігати позитивну динаміку,
хоч і не в мільйонних масштабах,
але все ж. Наприклад, у Баварії вітровими
електростанціями було вироблено 800 кіловат енергії.
Так, цього не достатньо, але 800 кіловат - це вже успіх.
Але це не допоможе нам до кінця року,
коли настане зима і президент РФ повністю
закриє газовий кран для Європи.
Так, я не планував змінювати тему,
лише хотів сказати, що у сфері захисту довкілля
теж триває клопітка робота.
Ви враховуєте можливість остаточного припинення
газових поставок із Росії?
Я не виключаю такої можливості.
Путін справді значно зменшив поставки газу.
Він чітко дотримується свого плану -
суттєво завищити ціни на газ в Європі
та Німеччині зокрема.
Він не стільки прагне економічно
ослабити Європу, як радше
похитнути впевненість нашого суспільства,
зруйнувати рішучість та
одностайність наших громадян.
І тому заходи, які ми вживаємо,
стосуються не лише енергетичної політики,
ці заходи спрямовані на зміцнення
єдності суспільства.
Ми не можемо дозволити Путіну перемогти.
Чи торкнеться підвищення
цін безпосередньо споживачів?
Довгострокові угоди не втратили своєї чинності.
Федеральне агентство з мереж ще не активувало
ціновий механізм, хоч часу й обмаль.
Але зрештою це означає,
що постачальники зможуть
передати ціни споживачам протягом тижня.
Це справді так?
Це палиця з двома кінцями:
з одного боку, для домогосподарств
з невеликим доходом
або для малого бізнесу
перехід виявиться надзвичайно тяжким.
З іншого боку, якщо не підняти ціни,
то не буде мотивації заощаджувати.
Якщо виробники не передадуть ціни споживачам, на
них цілком ймовірно чекатиме банкрутство.
Проблема в тому, що
великі енергопостачальники
уклали численні угоди про закупівлю газу.
І тепер постачання газу в
таких масштабах неможливе.
Але договори не втратили чинності.
Тепер вони мають закуповувати газ
на світовому ринку втричі дорожче,
ніж було закріплено в угодах.
Як би цинічно та парадоксально це не звучало,
з кожною кіловат-годиною
газу, який вони постачають,
ці підприємства зазнають збитків.
В якусь мить гроші на закупівлю газу закінчаться,
і жоден банк не видасть
кредит збитковому підприємству.
Після приватних підприємств така ж доля
чекатиме на комунальні,
а після комунальних підприємств -
і на кінцевих споживачів.
Такий собі ефект доміно на енергетичному ринку.
У будь-якому випадку ми маємо цьому завадити.
Одним із можливих інструментів є
передача вартості споживачам.
Але, як Ви правильно сказали,
це палиця з двома кінцями,
і з дуже гострими кінцями,
адже це може відбуватися доволі стрімко - тільки-но
розірвали старий договір і одразу ж уклали новий.
Цим аспектом не варто нехтувати, він може спричинити
величезну соціальну проблему в Німеччині.
Однак є й люди, які можуть заощаджувати газ.
Якщо я не помиляюся, у країні налічується
близько 20 млн домогосподарств,
які мають газове опалення.
Що ви могли б їм запропонувати?
Який стимул?
Лунають пропозиції нарахування спеціальних
бонусів за заощадження енергії.
Тобто, якщо людина споживає небагато газу,
менше, ніж минулого року,
вона отримує
грошову винагороду від держави.
Навіть не знаю, чи доречно зараз
говорити про винагороду.
Високі ціни на газ наразі є найкращим
стимулом заощаджувати.
Існує таке правило: кожен заощаджений градус тепла
у свою чергу заощаджує 5% енергії.
Відповідно, кожні два градуси - вже 10%.
А 10% такої високої вартості - це великі гроші.
Тому я вважаю, що в нашій системі вже передбачено
достатньо фінансових стимулів.
Я теж не хочу жити в країні,
в якій єдиним прагненням людей є грошова вигода.
У такі непрості часи необхідно подолати скнару
в собі та поглянути на речі глобальніше.
У моєму домі також газове опалення.
І не запитуйте, коли я востаннє
проводив гідравлічне балансування.
Але гідравлічне балансування справді допомагає
заощадити близько 15% енергії.
Звучить доволі дивно:
міністр економіки та захисту клімату Габек каже вам
замінити насадку для душу і таким чином
заощадити 30% енергії, сміх та й годі.
Насадка для душу врятує нас від Путіна.
Але якщо ви вирахуєте остаточну суму,
вам все стане зрозуміло.
Вона становить 40 млн домогосподарств.
Припустимо, що кожному домогосподарству,
або більшості з них,
вдасться заощадити 10% енергії,
а йдеться про 40 млн.
Тоді такі дії мають значення,
і я розраховую на них.
Адже це не весело,
оскільки ми опинилися в серйозній політичній,
суспільно-політичній ситуації.
Якщо ми не будемо допомагати одне одному,
то ми не впораємося з цим.
Якщо хтось скаже, що допомагатиме тільки,
якщо отримає 50 євро, я б сказав,
що ти їх не отримаєш, голубе.
З нами був федеральний міністр
економіки Габек. Дякую Вам.
Дякую.
Після випуску «journal» Мейбріт Іллнер та її гості,
серед яких Ларс Клінґбайль та Крістіан Лінднер,
обговорять цю тему знову.
Більше інформації щодо
дефіциту нафти й газу
ви знайдете на сайті zdf.heute.
Путін не має перемогти та розділити Європу.
Втримати ЄС разом було непросто
навіть у мирні часи.
Те, про що вчора оголосив
федеральний канцлер в парламенті,
фактично досягнуто
і це великий крок вперед та успіх.
Всі 27 країн-членів ЄС
проголосували за надання
Україні та Молдові статусу кандидатів.
Грузії, яка бажає
стати членом ЄС, навпаки,
потрібно набратися терпіння.
Відмова Україні та Молдові,
які безпосередньо межують з ЄС,
була б катастрофою європейської політики
з огляду на російську загрозу.
Про це розповість Ґуннар Крюґер.
30-метровий синьо-жовтий стяг.
Рішення про статус України
не залежить від євродепутатів.
Але вони попереджають,
що рішення мають ухвалити 27 країн-членів ЄС.
Їхнє «так» ніяк не вплине на дії ЄС,
однак для України воно цінне.
Обговорення завершилося
лише кілька хвилин тому
дописом у Twitter, який опублікував
президент Європейської Ради.
На саміті вирішилося питання
щодо надання Україні та Молдові
статусу кандидатів на вступ.
Історичний момент.
Так, це лише політичний меседж,
я це визнаю.
Скажу відверто, що
до членства нам ще далеко,
це може зайняти роки.
Те, що на рішення потрібно довго чекати,
пов'язано із самітами.
Ті самі 27 глав держав і урядів
зустрічаються з лідерами країн Західних Балкан.
Усі шість хочуть вступити до ЄС.
Переговори з Сербією тривають уже вісім років,
з Чорногорією – десять років.
Албанія та Північна Македонія
чекають початку переговорів.
Обидві країни будуть обговорюватись разом.
Тут втручається Болгарія,
прем’єр-міністр якої більше
стурбований кризою власного уряду.
Його країну заблокували
історичними аргументами.
Прогрес для України,
але не для Західних Балкан,
тому настрій був відповідний.
Хороша дискусія, скажімо, відкрита і вільна.
Мабуть, настільки відкрита,
що троє з кандидатів пройшли
спочатку скасовану
пресконференцію без лідерів ЄС.
Це ганьба для Болгарії, але й не тільки для Болгарії.
Причиною є нечесність
цього розголосу.
Прем'єр-міністр Албанії розкритикував Європу
і передає цей настрій вдома.
Ми знаємо, що в Україні йде страшна війна.
Я була б рада за неї,
але мені все одно буде шкода Албанії.
Вони мусять спочатку
розібратися з нами і Північною Македонією,
а потім з Україною.
Росія намагається вплинути на Західні Балкани.
Реакція ЄС на це злить кандидатів.
Потім вони скажуть,
що Путін – хвора людина.
Можливо, так, а можливо, з ним все добре.
Але це місце виглядає точно не дуже здоровим.
ЄС рухається вперед під тиском,
але без зайвих вагань стримує себе.
Дні в Брюсселі достатньо довгі для того,
щоб ЄС показав різні
погляди за короткий час.
Анне Ґеллінек з Брюсселя.
Вражає, як успіх України сьогодні
викликає обурення в інших країнах Європи.
Інший сценарій: Україну
змусять чекати стільки ж.
Злість та розчарування країн,
яких наздогнала та перегнала Україна,
можна було чітко побачити
на саміті Західних Балкан.
Протягом останніх років
тривають дискусії щодо розширення ЄС.
На одному з конгресів ЄС зазначив,
що Європа більше не прийматиме нові країни.
Дискусії щодо України продовжуються.
Після різкої критики з боку
шести глав урядів Західних Балкан
27 країн-членів ЄС почували себе винними.
Вони вважали,
що потрібно детально обговорити проблеми.
Зрештою, вони надали  Україні та Молдові
статус кандидата на вступ до ЄС.
Залишається запитання,
чи змусять Україну чекати стільки ж?
У ЄС не було вибору.
Було зрозуміло, що це політично неприйнятно -
зачиняти двері перед країною,
яка перебуває у стані війни.
Але також зрозуміло,
що це цілком символічне і політичне рішення,
яке ні до чого не зобов’язує.
Якщо подумати,
що Україну справді приймуть до ЄС,
то маємо найбільшу
за площею країну в ЄС з аграрною економікою,
яка отримує значні субсидії,
та величезним населенням, яке могло б утворити
меншину з іншими країнами.
Усі ці наслідки для ЄС
та його здатності функціонувати
тепер далеко відсунуті,
адже всі учасники знають,
що шлях України до ЄС
триватиме роками, а може й десятиліттями.
Звісно, ​​знають і в Києві,
що кандидатство на вступ
ще не означає вступ до ЄС,
але знак, що ці двері формально відчинені,
країна чекала дуже довго.
Під час війни такий жест підтримки
теж чекали з нетерпінням.
Детальніше розповість Домінік Лессмайстер.
У Києві вже майорять європейські прапори.
Багато людей в столиці України сподіваються,
що визнання країни кандидатом на вступ до ЄС,
зміцнить її позиції.
Вони дозволять нам бути членом ЄС.
Для нас це дуже добре і ми переможемо у війні.
Закони ЄС вимагають від нас багато.
Нам доведеться багато покращувати:
економіку, боротьбу з корупцією,
реформи законодавства.
Однак з погляду війни
Росія захоплює все більших
позицій на Сході України.
Повідомляється, що російські війська
стоять перед містом Лисичанськ на Донбасі.
Мета росіян, за словами українського генштабу, -
оточити місто, а отже, і українських військових.
Британська компанія телерадіомовлення ВВС
супроводжує волонтерів, які намагаються вивезти
мирних жителів з Лисичанська.
Колись тут жили сотні тисяч людей,
зараз в місті залишилося близько восьми тис.
Незабаром тут точитимуться вуличні бої
протягом тижнів, а може й місяців.
Ці люди не можуть залишатися.
Але багато з них не виїдуть, а отже, помруть
або житимуть у жахливих умовах.
Катя змушена покинути свій дім,
у якому виріс її син
Ми знаємо, що все це не закінчиться щасливо.
Після того, як вчора
на наше подвір’я впав снаряд.
ми втратили будь-яку надію
врятувати своє життя без допомоги.
Кажуть, що Росія зосередила на Донбасі
більше сотні реактивних систем залпового вогню.
Говорять про масовані обстріли.
Москва не показує сьогодні кадри військового потяга,
який, як кажуть, прямує в зону бойових дій.
Сигнал: російська атака триває.
А зараз Гайнц Вольф розповість
про руйнівний землетрус в Афганістані.
Надскладні рятувальні роботи.
На під’їзних дорогах
до віддаленого регіону катастрофи
є загроза зсувів, а також бракує техніки.
Тим часом прибули
перші постачання з-за кордону.
Декілька організацій допомоги,
а також федеральний уряд
пообіцяли швидку підтримку постраждалим.
За попередньою інформацією,
внаслідок землетрусу магнітудою 5,9 балів
загинула щонайменше тисяча людей.
Якщо ви хочете допомогти людям в Афганістані,
то Альянс з ліквідації наслідків стихійних лих
створив рахунок для пожертв,
який ви бачите на екрані,
ключове слово: ZDF Nothilfe Afghanistan
(Екстрена допомога Афганістану).
Ознайомитися детально можна на сайті «spender.zdf.de»
і в ZDFtext на сторінці 890.
У США Верховний суд розширив право
щодо носіння зброї в громадських місцях.
Це право захищене Конституцією,
і тому суд скасував закон штату Нью-Йорк,
який вимагав спеціальний дозвіл
на носіння зброї.
Президент США Байден висловив глибоке
розчарування та сказав,
що це рішення суперечить як здоровому глузду,
так і Конституції.
Федеральний міністр охорони здоров'я Лаутербах
очікує на нову потужну
хвилю коронавірусу восени.
Разом зі своїми колегами Лаутербах хоче
підготуватися до можливої
критичної ситуації з коронавірусом.
Відповідні заходи мають
бути представлені першого липня,
про це повідомили під час конференції міністра
охорони здоров'я у Магдебурзі.
Не було досягнуто згоди щодо спірного питання
продовження надання безкоштовних тестів
для громадян.
Лаутербах оголосив про нову концепцію,
яку він ще хоче погодити
із міністром фінансів ﻿Лінднером.
Через п'ять з половиною тижнів після виборів
у Північному Рейні-Вестфалії створено першу
чорно-зелену коаліцію.
Під час спільної презентації коаліційної угоди
з лідеркою партії Зелених Нойбаур
голова CDU Вюст сказав,
що вдалося узгодити передбачувані
протилежності,
щоб створити щось хороше.
Основна увага приділяється захисту клімату,
розширенню мережі громадського транспорту
та інвестиціям в галузь освіти.
Цими вихідними партійні з'їзди CDU та
Зелених ще мають бути узгоджені.
Коли йдеться про аеропорти,
берлінці звикли до труднощів.
Але коли черга перед контролем безпеки
в аеропорту Берлін-Бранденбург
була настільки довгою,
що люди стояли на вулиці,
то це сягнуло нового рівня розчарування.
Але зараз таке відбувається не тільки
в аеропорту Берліна.
Практично скрізь, не лише у Німеччині,
спостерігається постпандемічний хаос
у повітряному сполученні.
Скасування рейсів, затримки та
тривалий час очікування.
Згадуються прогнози на початку пандемії про те,
що використання повітряного транспорту
ніколи не буде таким, як раніше.
Але люди хочуть знову літати.
Багато авіакомпаній,
операторів аеропортів та охоронних фірм
переживають нестачу співробітників,
яких вони звільнили під час пандемії.
Далі про це - Томас Мюнтен.
Вчора ввечері, близько 19:00,
один із пасажирів зробив ці кадри на свій телефон.
У терміналі вильоту аеропорту Дюссельдорфа
відбуваються сутички між пасажирами,
деякі з них змушені чекати на перевірку безпеки
понад три години.
Федеральна поліція змушена втрутитися.
Опівдні тут уже було дуже людно.
Дисплеї терміналів приховують нескінченні черги,
що проходять через великий зал,
за невинним написом:
«Час очікування: понад 20 хвилин».
Пасажири в черзі здебільшого приголомшені.
Такого ніколи не було.
Такого не було навіть у найгірший сезон відпусток.
Я не міг уявити, що таке ще може бути. Неочікувано.
Якщо нам доведеться чекати ще
півтори години,
ми, найімовірніше, не встигнемо на літак.
Що можна сказати? Жах.
Приватні охоронні компанії влаштували
за﻿мало працівників охорони.
Наразі укомплектовано
половину ﻿контрольних маршрутів.
Із завтрашнього дня друга компанія відкриє
ще три маршрути.
Це дуже нестабільне становище,
вважає профспілка.
Якщо ми вже спостерігаємо таку картину,
ми не хочемо уявляти, що це означає,
коли в черзі стоять сім'ї з дітьми.
Оскільки це продовжуватиметься так само,
ми дуже стурбовані тим,
що ситуація тільки погіршиться.
Інспектори заробляють
від 19 до 26 євро на годину.
Але майже всі вони мають тимчасові
контракти на неповний робочий день.
Одна інспекторка розповідає нам про
свої будні. Вона хоче залишатися неназваною.
Коли нова компанія взяла на себе управління,
ще 100 осіб було звільнено, щоб
заощадити кошти.
Ми також маємо
постійно перерозподіляти наші зміни,
тому не можна спланувати іншу роботу.
А потім тебе ще ображають пасажири.
Ми нічого не можемо вдіяти.
У Баварії приватні компанії також
відповідають за перевірку безпеки.
Проте вже багато років вони повністю належать
федеральній землі,
вони не зобов'язані отримувати прибутки
та забезпечують безпроблемне обслуговування.
Ми виплачуємо зарплатню згідно з колективними
договорами, згідно із TVöD (державна служба),
працівники дуже задоволені.
Показник нестабільності у нас
становить менше, ніж 5%,
під час пандемії ми також нікого не звільнили.
Це суверенне завдання держави.
Мовою поліції це називається:
антитерористичні заходи, запобігання небезпеці,
і це завдання - в руках держави,
а не в руках орієнтованих на прибуток
охоронних компаній.
Адже це результат, який ми бачимо тут.
Ми хотіли б спитати про цю проблему
федеральну міністерку внутрішніх справ
Ненсі Фезер.
Через щільний графік
вона не могла дати інтерв'ю.
Попри зустріч із пресою у її будинку
сьогодні вранці.
Але проблеми не лише на землі.
Також не вистачає персоналу,
частково через велику кількість випадків
захворювання на коронавірус:
персонал відсутній через хворобу.
Більше щодо цієї теми розповість Гайнц.
А саме про плани авіакомпаній
на найближчий час.
Сьогодні пролунали новини про роботу Lufthansa.
Репортаж Франка Бетмана, яка зараз ситуація?
Треба сказати, що Lufthansa реагує по-новому.
Зважаючи на те, що ми щойно бачили.
Значна нестача персоналу.
Але є й внутрішні проблеми.
На початку місяця авіакомпанія скасувала
900 рейсів на липень.
Наразі скасовано ще 2200 рейсів.
У великих вузлових центрах Франкфурті
та Мюнхені
скасовані вильоти у липні та серпні.
Постраждали внутрішні та європейські маршрути.
Сьогодні Lufthansa виправдовує
це, зокрема, страйками
через проблему забезпечення безпеки польотів,
погодними явищами, а також підвищеною
захворюваністю.
Зазначається, що за останні кілька днів
члени екіпажів хворіли.
Після двох років пандемії
та численних звільнень
повітряний транспорт бореться
з надто малою кількістю персоналу
та надто великим робочим навантаженням.
Ситуація з фондовим індексом Dax завтра
також ускладниться.
Сьогодні він опустився майже на 1,8%
і становив лише 12 913 пунктів.
Побоювання щодо газу,
а також ослаблення економіки загалом
призвели до того, що ціновий барометр
сьогодні зазнає значних втрат.
А німецький індекс акцій наближається до
найменшого показника за рік.
На зв'язку був Франк Бетман, дякую.
Бундестаг схвалив підвищення BAföG,
фінансової допомоги студентам.
Згідно з цим рішенням
максимальна стипендія для студентів
зросте з 861 до 934 євро на місяць.
В майбутньому все більше молодих людей
матиме право на BAföG.
Крім того, передбачають збільшення
неоподатковуваної допомоги
на дохід для батьків.
Наразі Німецька метеорологічна служба
оголосила офіційне штормове попередження
з сильними грозами, зливами та градом
у деяких районах Баден-Вюртембергу та Баварії,
а також попередження про штормовий вітер.
Розпочалися фінальні змагання 2022 року:
чемпіонати Німеччини з 14 видів спорту.
Сьогодні був перший із чотирьох
днів змагань у Берліні.
Катрін Броєр починає з першого
чемпіонського звання
в новому виді спорту: швидкісне канополо.
Четверо проти чотирьох
посеред Шпрее біля East Side Gallery.
Канополо у новому швидкісному форматі.
Берлінський клуб «KSV Havelbrüder»
виграє у фіналі в ессенського
«Rothe Mühle» з рахунком 7:3.
У швидкого та захопливого спорту
з'явився перший німецький чемпіон!
Через район Мітте в Пренцлауер Берг,
на сім кілометрів далі на північ
в палаці спорту імені Макса Шмелінга
Леоні Адам здійснила свій фантастичний політ.
Нова чемпіонка Німеччини зі стрибків на батуті
показала найкраще виконання стрибків та сальто.
29-річна спортсменка здобула свій п'ятий
чемпіонський титул.
Фінальна бігунка Лена Майснер завоювала
титул чемпіона Німеччини
в змішаній естафеті для команди з Бушхюттена.
На Олімпійському стадіоні
команда захищає свій успіх
на спринтерській дистанції перед Потсдамом
та Берліном.
Завтра фінал можна буде побачити
у прямому ефірі на каналі ZDF
з 13:00.
Як було анонсовано,
відразу після погоди дивіться політичне
ток-шоу «Maybrit Illner».
О 00:30 чекайте на Крістофера Вермана
з «heute journal:update». До побачення.
Добрий вечір.
Сьогодні зранку над Францією сформувався
дощовий циклон.
Грози дійшли й до Німеччини,
а саме до Заходу Північного Рейну-Вестфалії,
до Баварії та Баден-Вюртембергу.
Ми бачимо, як це наближається із Франції.
Це накриє також Саар та Рейнланд-Пфальц.
Там також будуть сильні грози.
Грозовий фронт в Альгой
перейшов до регіону Фюнфсіленд.
На Північному сході країни буде спокійно.
Завтра між Рудними горами та Балтійським
узбережжям буде, як і раніше, дуже сонячно.
В інших регіонах - парко та волого.
Сильні грози, зливи та шквали.
Згідно з даними Німецької метеорологічної служби,
сильна злива означає,
що за годину випадає
щонайменше чотири см опадів.
Звучить цілком прийнятно.
Ці чотири сантиметри за годину
відповідають 40 літрам на квадратний метр.
Це чотири відра.
Припустимо, що така кількість
дощу випадає на один гектар.
Це 10 000 квадратних метрів,
велике футбольне поле.
Тоді це 40 000 таких відер
на годину - надто багато,
щоб поглинутися землею.
Якщо ця територія похила,
то водні маси стікають у долину,
де вони можуть перетворити
невеликі струмки на бурхливі річки
та викликати раптові повені.
Принаймні вихідні будуть спокійнішими,
до побачення.